as a woman in my seat and as a ceo i
feel the
responsibility to be an example of what
a more integrated masculine and feminine
leadership team and company looks like
[Music]
speculate we're trying to help companies
reimagine the way that they introduce
their employees to their roles so
instead of the age-old learning
management system where you go take a
course or instead of boot camps where
it's easy for employees to forget we
take all of your company knowledge and
training and surface it exactly where
the employee needs every step of the way
so it creates a much more
self-sufficient learning experience
i think i'm the person to tackle this
problem because i felt it firsthand my
dream wasn't to become an entrepreneur
initially but i worked in startups and i
worked in companies that were hiring
lots and lots of employees and launching
new business lines and constantly
changing and we really struggled with
helping keep all of our employees on the
same page and ensuring that they knew
all of our different tools and processes
and systems
and what i found is that
while in our personal lives everything
was instantly accessible on our
smartphones and personalized to us and
recommended to us
in the workplace you have to go digging
for information and that's really how i
started coming up with the idea for
respect and i was like well what if
where are the employees actually working
and spending their time
that information that they needed to
know how to do their job or how to do
that workflow was instantly accessible
to them
the challenge that i feel more now in my
role as ceo than i ever did as an
employee is really the
the pressure and probably it's pressure
that i'm putting on myself to do it
different
there's very very few women in our space
and growing up i think one of the
reasons i didn't aspire to be an
entrepreneur is i didn't have the visual
of what that looked like if anything i
think the visual of what a successful
woman looked like in movies was actually
something that made women shy away from
wanting to be that strong empowered
female leader and so i really see
this opportunity with speculators as an
opportunity to really show what the next
wave of female leadership looks like